meine erste rechtlich gesehen habe das
war nach 23 monaten
ich fand das nicht schlimm ich finde das
jetzt auch nicht schlimm aber ich fand
es interessant wie das aussieht
als ich mal wir das erste mal gesehen
habe mit seiner waffe unter dem ganzen
militär angezogen was
mein mann war dann so süß meint er hat
mir dann auch die schafe gekauft und
dann wollte ich ein paar baby kühe haben
die wollten wir dann auch holen ja ich
habe auch einen großen garten für den
kleinen war das schön
sie haben alle gleich geredet so wie ich
danach auch geredet habe al hamsa linda
inschallah der finger ich kann gut
schießen ich habe lange arme
wenn du handschuhe an hast kannst du die
waffen nicht durchschlagen weil dann 17
personen 14 ran dann
ist tot
man ist durcheinander wann kommt hin
wenn er wartet ein bisschen hilfe
wird nicht gemacht
irgendwo auch verständlich weil der
staat ich möchte aber ich bin jetzt auch
nicht mehr in ruhe gelassen wir haben
[Musik]